[Música]
es un placer saludarlos Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
por primera vez en más de 60 años se
redujo la tasa de natalidad en China
según estimaciones del registro de la
oficina Nacional de estadística de ese
país en 2022 se reportaron 850,000
nacimientos menos que en 2021 la
política del hijo único aplicada durante
décadas es una de las razones que
explica la baja tasa de natalidad Aunque
no es la única
Japón también reportó a finales de 2022
bajas cifras de nacimientos en buena
parte por la decisión de las mujeres de
no querer embarazarse al considerar que
esto frena su desarrollo profesional e
incluso personal lo veremos en esta
edición
Indonesia planea aquella carta deje de
hacer su capital para 2024 la razón la
ciudad se está hundiendo la creación de
su nueva capital nusantara ya está en
marcha por el impacto ecológico de
construir una urbe en reservas
tropicales podría ser un grave
inconveniente
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en China porque en
2022 se reportó una reducción en los
nacimientos en más de 60 años esto
coincide con las perspectivas que
señalan que este año china dejará de ser
el país más poblado del mundo situación
que pone en la alerta al gobierno de
China que ha optado por nuevas políticas
antes impensables como permitir tres
hijos por familia y crear un fondo
privado de pensiones en contraste India
pasará a ser la nación más poblada del
mundo con más de 1400 millones de
habitantes y una fuerza laboral que
promete impulsar su crecimiento
económico Samuel Salgado nos informa
china es el país con más personas en el
mundo su población supera la de
continentes enteros se estima que
actualmente hay 1.426 millones de chinos
Lo que equivale a dos veces la cantidad
de toda la población Europea y a la
población entera del continente
americano
una quinta parte de la humanidad es
china pero el gigante asiático está
viviendo una crisis demográfica y no
precisamente por la sobrepoblación sino
por el decrecimiento de la natalidad la
población cayó por primera vez en seis
décadas un giro histórico que se espera
que marque el comienzo de un largo
periodo de disminución en el número de
habitantes expertos señalan que el
decrecimiento se debe a las antiguas
políticas implementadas por el estado
Chino Sobre el control de la natalidad
en especial la ley del hijo único que
estuvo en vigor de 1980 a 2015 sin
embargo siete años después del fin de la
política el hijo único la tendencia de
fertilidad sigue a la baja
lo que preocupa al gobierno de shishin
Pink por las profundas implicaciones
para la economía Beijing ha decidido
introducir nuevas leyes que ahora
incentivan el nacimiento de incluso tres
hijos por familia
y el partido comunista chino optó por
abrir por primera vez en la historia de
la República popular un fondo de
pensiones privado que impulsa las
aseguradoras y administradoras de
activos extranjeros acelerar su
expansión en el mercado chino a pesar
del Rápido envejecimiento de su gente y
por lo tanto del aumento de la población
que está por fuera de la edad laboral
actualmente el 20% de los chinos tiene
60 años o más
los serios desafíos económicos que
enfrenta China la segunda Economía del
mundo la ponen en desventaja en la
competencia regional India la tercera
economía mundial con más de 1400
millones de habitantes superará en
población a China A mediados de abril de
este año según estimaciones de las
Naciones Unidas
en este hospital de la capital India
Nueva Delhi los médicos son conscientes
del alto número de nacimientos
lo positivo de los nacimientos es que
India tendrá un porcentaje muy alto de
población joven y eso es bueno para
nuestra economía
sin embargo la desventaja es que una
alta población pone una restricción a
nuestra comida a nuestra salud a la
educación
A diferencia de China India es uno de
los países con más jóvenes del mundo el
27% de los ciudadanos tiene entre 15 y
29 años lo que representa una gran
fuerza laboral
en esta misma línea Japón al igual que
china viene mostrando considerables
índices de descenso en los nacimientos
de acuerdo con el gobierno las cifra
estuvo por debajo de los ochocientos mil
durante el 2022 un número bajo si
comparamos la actual situación con los
nacimientos que se dieron tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial cuando nacían más
de dos millones de bebés en promedio
cada año que implica esta situación
significa que cada vez hay más adultos
mayores y cada vez menos trabajadores
jóvenes y por qué buena parte de las
mujeres ya no quieren ser madres veamos
el informe de nuestra corresponsal en
Japón luz a Medina
a sus 35 años haya casato decidió no
tener hijos su determinación de no ser
madre la hace formar parte de las
estadísticas de bajos embarazos en Japón
y la ha convertido en un activista
contra las desigualdades de género
estoy cansada de que la sociedad asuma
que las mujeres tienen que hacer todo el
trabajo de la y criar a los hijos y
luego volver a trabajar cuando ellos
crezcan
por eso he decidido no tener hijos para
no quedarme atrapada en este sistema
en los primeros 10 meses de 2022 en la
nación nipona sólo nacieron
669.871 bebés una cifra que representa
un mínimo histórico de nacimiento el
costo de la vida El impacto de la
pandemia y la cultura son algunas de las
causas de la disminución de los
embarazos según los especialistas
la tasa de natalidad en Japón disminuye
por dos razones la primera es que la
población de mujeres que pueden concebir
está en declive es decir algunas
personas que tuvieron hijos durante el
llamado baby Boom ya no están en edad
fértil y la población en condiciones se
reduce la segunda es porque en Japón
existe la cultura de tener hijos después
de casarse y la tasa de matrimonio
también decae como consecuencia de las
dificultades económicas el primer baby
Boom ocurrió después de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial y los nacimientos
alcanzaron los 2.5 millones Aunque el
tiempo de volver a estas cifras está muy
lejos existen japoneses que están de
acuerdo con tomar medidas para que las
mujeres se incentiven a tener hijos
sería mejor que ambos cooperen en la
crianza de Los hijos
es mejor para el futuro si los hombres
ayudamos más en la crianza de los hijos
en lugar de dejarle esta tarea solo a
las mujeres
pero sin incentivos ni apoyo para las
mujeres la población joven continuará en
declive
Así es Asia y se lo contamos en France
24 Estos son otros hechos destacados que
marcan la agenda del continente
en Corea del Norte las autoridades
ordenaron el confinamiento durante
algunos días en Peón yang la capital
debido al aumento de casos de una
enfermedad respiratoria por el momento
se desconoce el alcance de este virus de
si estaría relacionado con el covid 19 y
si la medida se extiende a otras
ciudades
en Nueva Zelanda Chris asumió como
Primer Ministro tras la renuncia de
2017 se convirtió en la líder más joven
del mundo con 37 años
que venía desempeñándose como ministro
de educación fue el único candidato
dominado para liderar el gobernante
partido laborista
India hizo gala de su poderío militar en
la conmemoración del día de la República
fecha en la que se repasa la historia
del país desde que entró en vigor la
Constitución de 1950 después de la
Independencia del imperio británico por
primera vez el desfile se llevó a cabo
en el renovado bulevar de la era
colonial que alberga los edificios
gubernamentales más importantes de India
tras años de renovaciones
se prevé que para 2024 nos Antara
reemplace a yakarta como la capital de
Indonesia Pero cuál es la razón según un
estudio de 2021 de la agencia para la
evaluación y aplicación de tecnología de
Indonesia yacarta se hunde en promedio
unos seis centímetros cada año debido a
la extracción excesiva de agua
subterránea por lo que una cuarta parte
del área de la capital estará
completamente sumergida para 2050 si no
se toman medidas urgentes Además del
aspecto económico que esto traerá
existen otros como el impacto que tendrá
sobre el medio ambiente pues ecologistas
aseguran que no saltara una región con
extensos bosques vería amenazada su
biodiversidad
Esta es la Zona cero de nusantara
el corazón de la futura capital de
Indonesia
se encuentra cerca de la costa en la
isla de borneo al borde de una de las
selvas tropicales más antiguas del mundo
un tesoro de biodiversidad
los objetivos iniciales de la empresa
masiva son construir un nuevo parlamento
y un palacio presidencial así como una
presa y una gran mezquita aprendemos
como la ciudad puede imitar el bosque el
hombre detrás del Mega plan asegura que
la nueva capital será inteligente y
sostenible una ciudad que trabaja con la
naturaleza y no en contra de ella
tenemos este principio no queremos
destruir la condición natural todos los
edificios Especialmente los edificios
clave o los edificios gubernamentales
deben ser edificios ecológicos tienen
que ser sensibles al medio ambiente
necesitamos usar materiales locales
tanto como sea posible
pero los ecologistas temen que las
intenciones ecológicas no sean
suficientes para proteger las Maravillas
naturales de La Isla que los indonesios
conocen como los pulmones del mundo
la nueva área de la capital estará justo
en el límite del área forestal protegida
de sungay wine si la construcción no se
gestiona bien Esto exacerbará las
amenazas existentes sobre el medio
ambiente
nu San tara se ubica a dos horas en
carro de la ciudad oriental de ballet
papan en kalimantán la parte Indonesia
de borneo que se comparte con Malasia y
brunei
La Isla alberga muchas especies en
peligro de extinción como el mono
narigudo y el orangután a medida que
avanza la construcción los activistas
advierten sobre los efectos de la
deforestación en los pocos habitantes de
la isla
estamos enfocados en el mayor desafío
para el futuro de los orangutanes su
hábitat natural sigue reduciéndose cada
día
la construcción debido a la creciente
población humana es el mayor desafío
no es solo la fauna y la flora únicas de
La Isla las que están en riesgo borneo
es también el hogar de varios grupos
indígenas incluido el pueblo balik
miles de ellos dependen del Bosque y del
entorno natural para sobrevivir los
funcionarios se han comprometido a
respetar sus derechos y compensar a Los
afectados por no pero muchos no quieren
ser reubicados de su hogar ancestral
incluso antes de que existiera esta
nación nuestros bisabuelos vivían en
esta área
[Música]
no queremos convertirnos en extraños en
nuestras propias tierras
la tierra es el mayor activo de nuestra
tribu es la fuente de vida si nos quita
nuestra tierra como podríamos cultivar
Cómo podríamos vivir
está previsto que la nueva capital se
inaugure en 2024 trayendo consigo una
ola de actividad humana e Industrial en
el entorno natural de borneo para 2045
el gobierno dice que la ciudad albergará
a 1,9 millones de residentes más del
doble de la población actual de la
región
y para cerrar Estos son algunos de los
productos principales que exportan
países asiáticos al resto del mundo
productos laminados de hierro y acero
autopartes alimentos lácteos semillas
soya aceites y cereales combustibles y
aceites crudos de petróleo equipos
electrónicos y de telecomunicaciones
medios de transporte como barcos y
automóviles lana y minerales como el
carbono
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]